pour voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis
mon petit doigt vient de me confier un
secret
il m'a dit nicolas et pimprenelle sont
allés se promener aujourd'hui dans la
campagne alors je descends vite les
voies car ils ont sûrement très faveur
mon le shell bros home pop et hip hop et
[Musique]
bonsoir les petits mon petit doigt m'a
dit que vous êtes allé à la campagne
regarde parce que nous avons quasi bon
le pulse
emprunt ou la wii telle horreur qu'est
ce que tu as j'ai vu de là dans le topic
au
nom mais elle va me piquer et l'eau
chaude avec nous pendant que nous
faisons a booké
manger à quatre fleurs ou lever l'euro
aussi un 4 e fleur d'une chambre haute
en couleurs et quand la nuit est arrivé
au le blues jouent quand la nuit est
d'agir et mes quatre fers pendant ces
jeux voltz a vu que du feu tomber mais
moi c'est
fini avec quatre commissions n'ont
d'autres champignons non d'autres
boutures on
met mois les et messieurs mes boutons de
rose dans ce tous les cadres andreu un
rigodon merveilleux comme le sommet y
élever le taureau jour c'est la planque
du nez dans l'art osé porter la voix des
clébards bouger pour le retour la
journée
les billets
coûtent 7 allons allons
aller là elle est partie en vouant
retourner la campagne ouf je n'en peux
plus cette coeur grand mère va être
posée groupe hurun nous on va s'coucher
pucelle bonne nuit mais plus
maintenant ça revient
oh
[Musique]
et
bravo nicolas
bravo pimprenelle vous avez fait un très
joli bouquet il n'y a pas d'odeur chez
vous pas trop non tu peux remonter sans
crainte nounours leggett ne pique que
sont les taquine
allons en route courageux compagnon en
route
bonne nuit des enfants fait de pour eux
[Musique]
oh
où
[Applaudissements]
oh
vous
[Musique]